اله الحرب والدمار لا تخمد في مدينه بخموت
فرغم الدفاع الاوكراني المستميت اكدت
موسكو انها ستقاتل حتى بص سيطرتها على
المدينه بحثا عن انتصار وان كان رمزيا
واملا في ان يفتح سقوط المدينه الطريقه
امام السيطره على المزيد من الاراضي في
منطقه دومباس فبعد تقدم احرزه مؤخرا يبدو
ان الروس يسيطرون على مداخل المدينه من
الشمال والجنوب والشرق ما يثير خشيه كياف
من محاصرتها في الاثناء اعلن الرئيس
الاوكراني
مقتل المقاتل الاوكراني الشهير ديميترو
كوتشو بايلو المعروف بكونية في ساحه
المعارك بمخموت مقاتل كان ينشط ضمن كتيبه
المتطوعين ومنحه الرئيس لقب بطل اوكرانيا
القومي الشهر الماضي
لقد قتل اليوم ديمترو كوتشي وبايلو في
معركه قربى بخموت دفاعا عن بلاده اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا متطوعا وشجاعا ومقاتلا مغوارا
انتفض وحمل السلاح ضد النفوذ الروسي منذ
عامه 2014 عندما كان مجرد مراهق واصبح
الان من بين الذين كتبوا اسمائهم وشجاعتهم
الى الابد في تاريخ اوكرانيا الى ذلك اجرت
موسكو وكياب عمليه تبادل جديده للاسرى وقد
اعلنت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه استعاده 130
عنصرا من القوات الاوكرانيه معظمهم كانوا
يدافعون عن مدينه ماريوبل الخاضعه للسيطره
الروسيه واخرون كانوا قد اعتقلوا في منطقه
بخموت والسوليدار في المقابل اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اعاده 90 جنديا روسيا من
اوكرانيا